la parole est à monsieur jean pierre
grand pour le groupe l'est républicain
et monsieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur en
septembre 2014 de très nombreuses
communes de l'hérault ont été sinistrés
par de violentes intempéries
on a eu à déplorer des victimes ces
épisodes de pluies diluviennes avec les
mêmes effets ravageurs se sont
reproduits fin en fin août nous avons eu
encore un déploré deux morts à
montpellier samedi et dimanche dernier
mon département était à nouveau durement
frappé par les plus torrentielles en
particulier dans le secteur du lodévois
et dans la vallée de l'hérault avec des
conséquences financières énormes pour
nos communes et de nombreux dégâts pour
les agriculteurs si les communes les
plus urbaines peuvent faire face à ces
dépenses exceptionnelles mais avec
difficulté
c'est totalement impossible pour les
plus petits villages qu'ils ne peuvent
assumer l'impérieuse et urgente remise à
l'état des voiries communales et des
chemins ruraux pour ne parler que de ces
équipements indispensables et
vulnérables les aides de l'état
commencent à arriver pour les
inondations de septembre 2014
un an après vous conviendrez monsieur le
ministre que c'est trop long pour les
maires ruraux le financement reste à la
charge de leur village entre les aides
diverses et le coût réel des travaux est
incompatible avec leur maigre budget
face à la répétition de tels phénomènes
météorologiques
il revient à l'état et au parlement
d'imaginer très vite des réponses
nouvelles pour que les plus petites
communes de france puissent faire face
comme toutes les autres à leurs
obligations de service public
cela s'appelle légalité républicaine de
nombreux maires sont désespérés de voir
leur impossibilité de financer les
dégâts causés par ces catastrophes
naturelles il est incontournable que
pour ses petites communes rurales les
aides publiques couvre 100 % du coût des
sinistres sur le ministre est il
possible de connaître également les
dates où seront pris les arrêtés de
catastrophe naturelle pour les épisodes
du 23 août et la semaine dernière
enfin je vous demande comment l'état
compte être rendez-vous la solidarité
nationale afin d'aider en urgence les
communes les plus durement touchés ma
question se pose également pour les
viticulteurs et toutes les productions
agricoles sinistrées dans l'hérault
votre réponse monsieur le ministre est
attendu par les élus locaux et par le
monde agricole qui n'en peut plus
d'avancé merci pour eux monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur se 15,9 pour
répondre à notre question appelle des
réponses extrêmement précise d'abord il
est vrai que le département de l'hérault
comme le département du gard ont été
frappés par des épisodes météorologiques
extrêmement sérieux et répéter ça a été
notamment le cas la semaine dernière
avec les événements qui ont frappé le
lodévois le gange également à proximité
des cévennes et puis dans le département
du gard les communes de vals rogge les
communes thales et un certain nombre de
communes aux environs vous insisté sur
la nécessité de procéder rapidement à
l'indemnisation des communes concernées
de manière à ce que la vie puisse
reprendre normalement et je voudrais
vous apporter un certain nombre de
réponses précises d'abord pour ce qui
concerne les événements qui se sont
produits à la fin du mois d'août c'est à
dire qui ont précédé ceux du week-end
dernier la commission interministérielle
se réunira le 22 septembre prochain et
l'ensemble des dossiers qui ont été
portés à la connaissance de l'état
pourront être examinés à cette occasion
deuxième point pour ce qui concerne les
événements de vous parlais à l'instant
j'ai donné instruction au préfet de
l'hérault de bien vouloir prendre
contact avec l'ensemble des communes
concernées de manière à ce que les
dossiers d'indemnisation puisse être
complétée le plus rapidement possible il
ya vingt-deux communes avec lesquels il
est d'ores et déjà en contact ce qui
permettra de réaliser très rapidement
ces dossiers de procéder à
l'indemnisation
troisième point vous insisté sur la
nécessité d'une indemnisation rapide des
communes et notamment sur la possibilité
d' indemniser à 100 % les plus petites
communes pour lesquelles ces événements
météorologiques sont un désastre et
elles ont peu de ressources pour pouvoir
réparer les dégâts occasionnés par ces
tempêtes
là aussi des éléments de réponse
concrets j'ai voulu modifier la
procédure qu'ils étaient trop longues ou
même souligner et un décret a été pris
le 18 juin 2015 il
quelques semaines qui va permettre
d'avancer dans trois directions d'abord
les délais d'instruction seront
raccourcis parce que le délai d
expertise sera moins important et le
processus d' expertise sera
considérablement simplifié deuxièmement
j'ai demandé à ce que l'on augmente le
niveau des avances faites aux communes
et troisièmement j'ai demandé à ce que
l'on puissent fusionner les fonds
d'indemnisation dans le cadre de la loi
de finances pour 2016 pour ce qui
concerne les agriculteurs
le dispositif calamités agricoles en
liaison avec le ministère de
l'agriculture sera enclenchée très
rapidement enfin pour ce qui concerne
les petites communes
répondant à la préoccupation par
anticipation qui est la vôtre j'ai
inscrit dans le décret du 18 juin 2015
la possibilité de procéder à
l'indemnisation à 100% des travaux à
réaliser pour ces petites communes
au terme des dégâts occasionnés par les
tempêtes les préoccupations vous
exprimer sont tout à fait légitimes et
le gouvernement a souhaité y répondre
au regard des catastrophes qui sont
produits notamment dans votre
département en 2014 et qui ont conduit
d'ailleurs ces événements
météorologiques à l'indemnisation des
communes de l'hérault pour 2014 à
hauteur de 14 1 millions d'euros
merci monsieur le ministre